for nearly 20 years journalists souad
mechanic has covered some of the world's
most dangerous conflicts she's gained
rare access to the inner circles of
groups like the Taliban al Qaeda and
Isis in 2015 she co-wrote the
blockbuster Washington Post article that
unmasked Isis killer jihadi John as
British citizen mohammed emwazi her
latest book recounts some of her most
dangerous reporting assignments it's
called I was told to come alone my
journey behind the lines of jihad so I'm
mechanic welcome great to have you here
thanks want to get to the book but first
I want to get your take on the latest
news I'm just looking at the wires right
now that Syrian democratic forces have
captured several strategic neighborhoods
just outside isil's de-facto capital of
Raqqa what's the significance of that
well we have to see first when they will
capture all of Raqqa I and it depends on
if you read now the the newsletters that
are coming out from Isis you will read a
totally different story what they say is
that they're fighting back that they're
killing a lot of forces so but if indeed
this is true it could mean that the
us-backed forces are gaining ground but
it doesn't mean that this will destroy
Isis the ideology is going to live on I
think that leadership is still there in
Raqqa well what we are hearing is that
the leadership has moved to other places
or was moved to other places because
Charlie Isis knows and they knew that
this would happen that at some stage the
us-led and backed forces would go after
them and they have taken precautions if
you follow the media outlets that are
coming from amaq news agency which is
the Isis owned owns agency you will see
that actually it's pretty much
functioning so it does it does mean that
while that the the Isis structure isn't
it is still still still still going on
there but it also means the loss of the
Caliphate well the loss of the Caliphate
as a as a as a country as it yes but not
as an idea and this is the danger could
I just say you were very brave I think
this book started in part after 9/11
where a widow of one of the firefighters
said to you why do they hate us so much
yes and you went on a journey to find
out the answer to that question to hear
the other side so you go into some very
dangerous situations you're told to come
alone no ID no purse no cell phone and
you trusted them at times you had to
trust them at times to gain access how
were you able to do that well it's of
course it took a lot a lot long time too
a lot of gain that kind of access but
also a lot of planning so when when when
we come to an agreement to me there's of
course always the danger that they would
change their eye or mind their mind or
that maybe one of the questions I ask is
not like very much and that they react
or act in a way that will endanger me
but it's a choice I made gale because I
really feel that if we want to find
solutions and for fighting extremism or
terrorism we do have to understand
what's going on in their hearts and
minds otherwise it's not going what if
you look what did you learn well I
learned that when I sit down with them
with most of those guys they don't speak
to me about religion for example they
talk a lot about politics about
international policies about what they
called hypocrisy of our own Western
democracies they talk about how we
preach human rights and freedom of
speech and expression but that we are
indeed using double standards they are
using at the moment for example also
some of the things that President Trump
said during the election campaign about
Muslims in order to tell Muslims in the
West look you will never be part of this
of this society so just you know come
and join the caliphate it's one thing to
say that is it not it's another thing to
be doing some of the kind of
cold-blooded things that they have done
in terms of Manchester or in terms of
cities in Europe as well as what
absolutely you're absolutely right and
it's a difference and you have to point
that different down well it's it's very
it's very important for me to also point
out when is the you know when do we lose
those people for example the Manchester
bomber because he grew up in the West on
mohammed emwazi jihadi john' there's a
certain point
where
where we lose them into the hands of
this recruiters and this is why I wrote
and that you have said in the book that
when you were a young Muslim woman in
Germany you might have been susceptible
to a recruiter because there was a there
was a moment in my life and I believe
that this is very important to mention
in the book there's a woman there was a
moment in my life where I felt I was no
longer accepted in that society but I
was lucky Charlie I grew up in a you
know in a household my I grew up in
Morocco partially and then in Germany
where I had parents and grandparents who
taught me that we have so much more in
common with people of different
religions then what is dividing us and
this is why I say also in the book words
matter if people today only talk about
what is dividing us this is only helping
those who want to recruit people and you
talked about the help of a Muslim woman
who is Sonia yeah Sonia who turned the
case in France if it wasn't for her
information that story might have not
have turned out the way that it did and
those are the untold stories that are so
important to tell because without her we
would have had another attack in Paris
right she dumped that one thank you so
very very fascinating hook thank you
congratulations thank you so much the
book is called I was told to come alone
that title was very appropriate for that
book it comes out tomorrow